let's get the reaction now from the
labour party we can speak to the chavez
scottish secretary in murray thank you
very much for being here
uh with us well let's talk about this
resignation what is your reaction oh
well we're not shocked because this is
the second ethics advisor that these
prime ministers have don't forget that
sir
alexander allen who was the previous
ethics advisor resigned two years ago
because he wrote a report into the
current home secretary bullying staff
and the prime minister backed pretty
patel and therefore he resigned so lord
guy came into the role from then um and
although his statement tonight doesn't
really say very much he has in the last
few weeks said that the prime minister's
ridiculed uh the ethical code the
ministerial code he said that he's been
skirting around the edges of the
ministerial code and i think his ethics
adviser had just had enough and the
ridicule of the ministerial code when he
said that that was a few weeks ago when
he had produced the report in terms of
the prime minister's uh attitude to the
ministerial code when he said that he
should have been explaining all the way
through partygate
he said that he should uh explain why he
didn't believe he wrote the ministry and
he used the word ridicule the
ministerial code so there's little
wonder that lord gait has had to resign
because it's quite clear that the prime
minister has broken the ministerial
court he will now go to the privileges
committee um and you know the history is
there for people to see that what he's
been saying in parliament and what's
been happening and downing street and
you know the prime minister will now no
longer get an ethical advisor i mean who
would want to do that job it'd be trying
to find similar to trying in hannibal
lecter a dentist i would imagine in
terms of what the job would entail now
for someone who wants to try and keep
this prime minister ethical i mean it's
difficult though isn't it because we we
don't know why he resigned yes we can
obviously make the suppositions we know
of course he is in front of the
parliamentary committee
we know of course that he has expressed
frustration about how the prime minister
dealt with partygate
but it's not a smoking gun unless he
tells us why he resigned does it
well and he may tell us why he's
resigned but the word ethics and this
prime minister don't really go very
comfortably together and if you're the
prime minister's ethics advisor and
trying to advise on him sticking to the
ministerial code he's been fined by the
police he's been shown to at least have
lied in parliament whether that be
intentional or not and the privileges
committee will look at that so the job
that he's been asked to do is almost an
impossible job and he's decided
obviously to leave his role and i hope
in the next few days he does
what public service should do and what's
in the public interest and tells us
exactly why he's resigned and the the
details of the information that the
prime minister has got in terms of
history do you think as a public servant
he should explain the the reasons i
think it's in the public interest to do
so this is the second ethics adviser to
resign with this prime minister because
the prime minister hasn't been listening
to the advice that they had employed it
to give him he's already said a few
weeks ago that he thinks that the prime
minister should have been explaining why
he was sticking to the ministerial code
or not in terms of partygate and he
hasn't done that he's used the word
ridiculing the ministerial according
today has decided to resign and i think
the public will look on this and realize
that the prime minister has now lost two
ethics advisors in the last two years
and that really is quite unacceptable in
the current environment okay um we've
been talking a bit about rwanda uh today
keen to get your opinion on that would a
labour government cancel the agreement
with rwanda and stop sending asylum
seekers there well of course because we
wouldn't have it in the first place you
know it's quite clear that this is
unworkable it's unethical it's costly
and it's indeed illegal so would you
cancel it then we would yes i mean
that's but it's pretty clear i think
ivette cooper the shadowholm secretary
was clear about that in the chamber
today she completely tore this policy
apart and let's be quite clear about
what this policy is doing it's taking
asylum seekers who are crossing the
channel dangerously in dinghies sticking
them on planes to rwanda and if their
asylum
application is successful under the
rules of the uk's asylum processes they
stay in rwanda that's unethical and it's
unworkable and it's hugely expensive and
it's interesting that i don't know if
tom said that in his interview with you
a few minutes ago but i don't know if he
told you how much this was going to cost
because the home secretary refuses to
tell us so it's quite clear that this is
a policy that's just about extending the
culture wars it does nothing to stop
people crossing so what is your strategy
then
because this is what the government says
it says look we had 440 uh people trying
to make that crossing yesterday it's
incredibly dangerous there's got to be
something to stop it what's your
strategy well what the government
government are trying to do what's your
structure well this is what i'm going to
tell what the government are trying to
do is to take the people off those boats
and send them to rwanda what they really
need to be trying doing is have a
relationship with the french and the
belgians to be able to try and stop
these questions from happening go after
the criminal gangs
you've got to go after the criminal
gangs it's not two years
not taking people out of dinghies and
sending them to rwanda now you said
there was 444 yesterday that's with the
rwanda policy so it's quite clearly not
going to work and it's unethical and
it's completely utterly unworkable and
of course it is now deemed to be illegal
as well so we need those um criminal
guides taken out it's really strange the
home secretary spent all of her time
creating a relationship with a country
like rwanda and none of our time talking
to the french or indeed the belgians in
terms of this issue we need to go after
those criminal gangs to stop those boats
coming across and maybe we need another
dublin arrangement which need to work on
so that asylum seekers can be dealt with
in the country they first arrive in uh
okay let's uh just finally i want to
talk to you a little bit uh with your uh
scotland hat on because a nicholas
sturgeon yesterday was vowing to push
ahead with the idea of a second
independence uh referendum
now if you look at the current polling
local elections the current polling
everything is pointing towards hung
parliament uh in westminster uh it would
be a lot easier for labour of course to
form a government in that case uh rather
than conservatives
would you be prepared to do a deal with
the snp no no there'll be no deals into
the election there'll be no deals coming
out of the election and our challenge to
the snp if labor for the administration
is the largest party would be do what
you did in 1979 if you wish to bring in
another conservative government or back
the labour administration that would be
well that is a deal
isn't it saying that you'd back the
labour administration well they would
have to decide vote vote if they wanted
to either vote with us or vote with the
conservatives that's not a supply
arrangement there's no arrangement
whatsoever his care has been clear time
and time again and our sabbath has been
clear and will continue to be clear no
deal is going into the election none
coming out because we don't require even
if it lets the conservatives into power
it will let the conservatism departure
for the largest party because the sap
would have to decide s p would have to
decide to vote with the conservatives to
bring it down a labour government i'm
not sure they would do that i don't
think it's under political interest to
do that and if they like us
share the view that we want to get rid
of this conservative government then the
people of scotland when they're voting
the next general election can do that by
voting labour okay ian murray thank you
very much for being on the program